the big news of the weekend is this
infrastructure bill
and i want to start off real simply i
don't like politics
i don't adhere to nor identify with any
political parties
i believe that individuals can hold
multiple ideas in their brains and
adhere to or support both sides
on different issues that's fine i
actually also think that there is a
third side which is basically the
independent side the side
that allows people to think for
themselves now what we're watching
in the infrastructure bill is we have a
550
billion dollar bill that is over 2 700
pages long
and this bill is supposedly focused
on the infrastructure of america when
you hear infrastructure in america
people get excited
yes let's go build roads and bridges and
fix our trains and
do all the things that infrastructure
would insinuate but as we know from last
week
i read the bill or at least parts of it
and there's not a lot of infrastructure
in it
in fact there's things like invasive
plant
species removal there is potentially
the authorization for the us government
to buy weed
to study driving high they also added in
an amendment
towards the end of last week and over
the weekend that specifically services
the food and beverages on the amtrak
so not lots of infrastructure about 10
or so from the numbers i've seen
actually goes through true
infrastructure but 550 billion
now this bill has been held up by one
specific section it's about three or
four paragraphs
that relies on or analyzes
or legislates the crypto industry now
it is part of something a part of the
bill that is supposed to
pay for the cost so what they do is they
create here's all the ways that we're
gonna spend money and then here's the
things that we're gonna do in this bill
that's gonna help us generate revenue
and we take that revenue and we're gonna
use it to spend
that hopefully or at least theoretically
would prevent them from printing money
whole different issue
one of the things that they are using to
generate revenue
is that they want to more clearly tax
the bitcoin and crypto world and the way
that they want to do that is they want
to go after something called a broker
now a broker has all sorts of kind of
definitions
and legal ramifications for the
terminology that's used but essentially
a broker is
somebody that allows one party and a
second party to interact with each other
to transact etc
now the problem with the original bill
was that it was not clear who fell under
a broker
and who did not fall under that
definition and so that's what the debate
has been
now i personally believe that majority
of the politicians
one have not read the bill two they
actually have
no clue what crypto is or bitcoin is or
how it works or what the underlying
technology is or what the promise of the
technology is
and three that they don't actually want
to be malicious they do not want to hurt
innovation in the country
and so when you put together people who
have not read the bill people who don't
understand the industry
but also people who don't want to
actually hurt the industry
what you get is a lot of good-natured
effort but not great results and that's
what we're seeing right now
and so we've seen over the last couple
of days
multiple amendments have been proposed
and on top of that we've
also seen incredible engagement uh
and kind of um you know rallying around
this
from the bitcoin crypto world now i
never thought
that on this show we would be pulling up
all sorts of the content that we're
about to pull up but what's important to
remember
is that bitcoin specifically for me
personally bitcoin taught me economics
bitcoin taught me personal finance and
now bitcoin is teaching me
exactly how the political system works
and so coming from somebody who
literally went to college and studied
economics i've learned more about it
by buying holding and studying bitcoin
than i have in almost anything else i've
done in my life the same thing with
personal finance
and now the same thing with politics and
what we're seeing is this type of
11th hour legislation is nonsense
the point of government is to serve
and represent the will of the people and
so we've got two quotes as
a reminder off the top as to what the
point of government and elected
officials are
the first comes from thomas jefferson
when government fears the people
there is liberty when the people fear
the government
there is tyranny the government is there
to serve the people and when the
government fears the people there is
liberty
the second quote comes from alan moore v
for vendetta
and it reads quote people shouldn't be
afraid of their government
governments should be afraid of their
people
same exact energy some may say
trillionaire energy actually
the government is supposed to be a
representation
of the people's will if the people do
not want something the government should
not do it
if the people want something the
government should do it and if the
people of an industry
are all collectively saying hey we are
some of the most tribalistic industries
in the world
we constantly fight with each other we
constantly attack each other but
together we are united on this specific
front
that you do not understand this industry
you do not understand the underlying
technologies
you are asking for something in this
legislation that is not technically
possible
please do not do it the government
should listen
your elected officials should say what
is the will of the people and that is
how i will vote
and so as we talked about this 11th hour
governance
does not work yesterday ted cruz
came out of left field and was firing
off tweets
and i gotta say there's a lot of people
who disagree with ted cruz on a lot
but he got this one right i saw people
on both sides of the political aisle
coming out and saying
ted cruz nailed it and his point was
that after the vote
the senate said tonight let's tax the
hell
out of something we know nothing about
so we can pass a giant bill
we haven't read and spend the american
people's money
on stuff we can't afford it's reckless
and harmful
the last time people heard about ted
cruz he was on a flight to cancun to
drop his kids off and then he came back
the next time that you guys heard us
talk about ted cruz was when he was
wearing
his pickup basketball outfit to actually
go there is
to go and do a vote in congress ted cruz
isn't exactly the person
that most people would point to and say
that's the most rational person in the
world whether you like him or not
he's right here he nailed it let's tax
the hell out of something we know
nothing about so we can pass a giant
bill we haven't read
and spend the american people's money on
stuff we can't afford
it's crazy now in light of this
what we have seen is that the mainstream
media
washington dc and the political class
got slapped upside their head in the
last couple of days by the crypto
industry
they've been awoken to the beast of the
community
and what i mean by that is we can look
at some of the mainstream
media's press headlines for example on
the left
how cryptocurrency became a force in
washington
or on the right washington wakes up to
crypto influence amid infrastructure
fight
the bitcoin and cryptocurrency industry
is full of young people who are highly
engaged
who understand the internet who spend
all day
conducting the war of ideas
in a digital public space like twitter
or reddit
and now there has been enormous wealth
generated in this industry bitcoin
and crypto has gone from zero dollars in
market cap
to almost two trillion dollars in about
12
years the amount of wealth that has been
generated in this industry
is incredible there are
a handful more than a handful of
multi-billion dollar
companies that have been created in a
12-year period
it is estimated that half of the forbes
400 list
will come from the bitcoin and crypto
world by the time that bitcoin hits
about 175 000 to 200
000 in price that is incredible
concentration of wealth
from a single industry and so when you
start to think about the ramifications
of this
the challengers end up succeeding
they end up garnering wealth and then
they turn and they become interested
in topics that have to do with the
organization of resources with the
governance of populations
and with the tax structures in which
they will be asked to live in
that is what we are watching in real
time is a 550 billion dollar
infrastructure bill
is being held up over the vernacular
used in a couple of paragraphs
by an industry that most people in
washington
barely knew existed until recently and
they brought
that entire bill to a screeching halt
until it can be
resolved they are melting the phones of
the senators
they're tweeting at them incessantly and
what it ultimately
shows is that the power structure is
changing
because for decades we have seen the
political class
use the tools in their toolbox to try to
affect
change that change has been driven
by words politicians
simply have words they can use words on
a piece of paper
or they can use words that come out of
their mouth but that
is what their tool set encompasses
they can use words and those words
have fallen on deaf ears for decades
they have been highly ineffective at
creating change in the financial system
creating more transparency
and creating more accountability at the
same time
that the average age of these
politicians being in the late 50s or
early 60s
and the use of words as the tools in the
toolbox
have been ineffective young people
mainly
have used technology and used
entrepreneurship
and their skills of innovation and
creativity
to build a better system so the
political class
tried to beg and complain
and to advocate for their way to change
of the legacy system
while young people use technology to
simply build a better one
and now what we have is we have the most
transparent financial system in the
world
has been created all without
true centralized leadership all without
the need
or reliance on any one government or
geography
or any one company and so what we are
watching
is that the political class is
completely unprepared
for a new class of doers the doers
have been more effective in a 12-year
period than
decades of work by the political class
and what we are watching is there is a
bifurcation in the political class
one half of the political class or more
believes that they can continue to use
words
to beg and complain and advocate
against this new class of doers but
there
are a few politicians that understand
where the future is going
they understand the shift of power they
understand that this new class of doers
is likely to only continue to make more
and more progress
in the future and this new class of
doers will bring more innovation
economic prosperity and jobs to our
country than almost any other industry
that exists today
and those select politicians whether at
the local level like miami mayor francis
suarez
they're in the senate like senator
lumbus or they're in congress
like somebody like congressman davidson
or they're even at a regulatory body
like the sec
with sec commissioner hester purse
they see the future they understand that
getting in the way of this industry
is simply picking up pennies in front of
a steamroller and it
is not going to be kind from a
historical perspective
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show make
sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com
so that you can get an account we can
get after it